and the Oscar goes to Joaquin Phoenix
joke Joaquin Phoenix finally wins an
Oscar after three previous nominations
for gladiator walked the line and the
master the forty five-year-old picked up
the Best Actor trophy for his
performance in Joker beating out fellow
nominees Antonio Banderas Leonardo
DiCaprio Adam driver and Jonathan price
comes so much gratitude right now and I
do not feel elevated above any my fellow
nominees or anyone in this room because
we share the same love that the love of
film I don't know what I'd be without it
Joaquin went on to say that his greatest
gift has been the opportunity to use his
platform for the voiceless that to get
times we feel or were made to feel that
we champion different causes but for me
I see commonality I think whether we're
talking about gender inequality
or racism or queer rights or indigenous
rights or animal rights we're talking
about the fight against injustice we're
talking about the fight against the
belief that one nation one people one
race one gender for one species has the
right to dominate control and use and
exploit another with impunity he also
thanked Hollywood for giving him
multiple chances I've been a scoundrel
in my life I've been selfish I've been
cruel at times hard to work with and I'm
grateful but so many of you in this room
have given me a second chance a visibly
emotional Joaquin even paid tribute to
his late brother River Phoenix when he
was 17 my brother wrote over this lyric
he said run to the rescue with love and
peace
we'll follow the passionate speech
earned him a standing ovation
of course Joaquin's Oscar is just the
icing on his award season cake he also
brought home a Golden Globe and a SAG
Award and let's not forget his wins at
the BAFTAs and Critics Choice Awards
joaquin delivered a powerful speech at
each stop touching on everything from
climate change to systemic racism oh
yeah he also wore the same suit to every
award show as an act of sustainability I
thought that it was gonna be challenging
for me as an actor I thought was gonna
be challenging for the audience and
that's exciting to me personally I'm
just super interesting about it
Phoenix is the second actor to win an
Oscar for playing the Joker
after Heath Ledger's posthumous win for
The Dark Knight in 2009
[Music]